Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Tutters again, this will be a short video on a product
that we use in the office and that I personally take called Live Tun Complex and it has
to do with helping the liver detox pathways.
So remember when we talk about detoxification and a person being toxic, that's probably one
of the biggest comments in the office again, I guess I need to detox, I need to detox.
Well, it is true, if you are not detoxing, you're going to be dead.
So your body is detoxing, your detox is through the lungs, the skin, the gut, the intestines,
the kidneys.
But most things have to go through the liver, so we can't talk about detoxification without
talking about the liver detoxification pathways.
This is a big reason why we look at genetics in a person because we want to look at defects
on the specific detoxification pathways.
Everything that you consume, whether you breathe it into the toxin, goes across the alveolar
spaces in the lungs, whether you spill it on your skin and you absorb it through the skin
into the bloodstream, or whether you ingest it, it goes through the gut and absorbed into
the bloodstream.
Sooner or later, it's going to go through the liver.
So supporting these liver pathways with a general herbal formula without knowing your
genetics can be very beneficial.
So if we know your genetics, then we can be more specific, but without knowing them, you
can use a general detox support.
So these herbs that are in live tonne, the globe artichoke, dandelion root, milk thistle,
belirum, root, fringe tree, stem bark, extract, are good herbs to help stimulate many of
the liver detox pathways.
Milk thistle is probably the number one herb that you think of with liver detox pathways.
Many herb is the brand of the product that we're talking about.
They have a track record of sourcing good materials, and that's what it's all about.
So you can certainly go to big market store, like Costco, or something like that, of
not knocking Costco, or Target, or anything like that, and you can buy these herbs, but
there is no FDA approval on those things.
So you are trusting the company that you're buying them from, and there's a reason why they're
real cheap, because there's been studies, independent studies, which bought supplements from
these companies, and they found very little of actually what was listed on the label in
the supplement.
So you have to buy from a company that you trust the source, and they do independent testing.
And I've seen many herbs standard process plant, like I've visited many of the plants that
we source from, source is all important, and otherwise it's worthless.
So you're not really taking any things.
These are great products, this is a great product that I take personally, and one that you
can find in our stores, if you go to CuttersClick.com and you go to our store, it could be purchased
through that, and you can just take what's on the label, I think it's two to four a day.
All right, thanks so much.